today we are heading off planet earth
and going to the moon
the moon is back in vogue again whether
it's the united states or china or
billionaires
lots of people seem to want to go there
and we're going to talk
to a person named jessie kate shingler
she's worked at nasa ames she's worked
at a rocket company
and she is part of an organization
called open lunar
it's a non-profit and they're doing
something
that's really interesting rethinking
different ways that we
might govern and set up settlements
on the moon and maybe find a way to
do things better and at least
differently on the moon than we have
on on earth with that we are going to go
to france
where jessie kate is spending a little
covered time
[Music]
well thanks for doing this with us can
you for people who don't know
about the open lunar foundation can you
tell us what
the mission is yeah open lunar is
interested in seeing a peaceful and
cooperative
sustained human presence on the moon
and ensuring that that happens in a way
that
is open and accessible and uh
you know as as soon as possible i'm not
sure that unless you're if you're just a
casual
observer of all this stuff that people
are fully aware of how much
reinvigorated interest there is in the
moon right now
tell me you know if we think globally
what's going on between china and the us
and various factions trying to try to
get to the moon in the next few years
the united states uh has been and
continues to be
one of the major players in the space
industry
it has a program called the artemis
program that is focused on getting
humans back to the moon
for the first time since the apollo
program during the apollo program
russia of course was the the major other
player in the space
world uh and that introduced a dynamic
that was you know a cold war dynamic
where russia
and the united states were competing for
uh getting to the moon first
today what we see is something that has
some analogs to that between
the united states and china who is the
other major state
actor in the space world china also has
plans to go to the lunar surface with
humans
with taikonauts and both united states
and china have plans to set up a
base of some kind or an outpost on the
lunar surface
but of course they're not the only ones
interested in going to the lunar surface
there are a lot of other countries who
are developing capabilities either to
collaborate with those countries
or to send their own missions and then
there are private actors who are
planning to go to the lunar surface
of course everybody's familiar with
spacex and blue origin at this point
and they're companies that have
leadership with a very strong vision for
seeing a sustained
human presence on the lunar surface and
then i mean like if you go back 10 years
ago
right when spacex was was kind of
starting to hit its stride and
and bezos was putting a lot of money
into blue origin i mean it seemed like
mars
you know elon's very focused on mars and
mars was like the
the talk and obviously there's things
you can do there that you can't do on
the moon but it's kind of funny i mean
the moon like
just sort of came back in vogue very
quickly it felt like
to me i mean you know what do you why do
you think
that is if you think if if you do think
that's what actually kind of happened
yeah i mean um you know in the space
community of course we love to debate
moon versus mars
and uh and it's fun and they're they're
very different places
and there are a lot of reasons for us to
go to mars but the moon
is uh much closer and it's somewhere
that we can
go and sort of learn the ropes of uh
having human presence and extended human
presence in outer space
we can get our transportation systems in
order we can get our human habitation
systems and order our communication
systems in order so you know i think
most folks with a kind of long-term
vision
for space exploration and settlement in
general
would see them not as being in
competition with one another but
but the moon is being a stepping stone
uh to mars and other kinds of activities
uh and just building on our presence on
the moon hope you know hopefully what
we'll see
is uh the development of sustained human
presence on the moon and going to mars
and i wanted to i wanted to get into a
little bit about
why you're so into the moon and in space
in general you have this you have a
pretty interesting history when it comes
to
all this tell me you know tell me a
little bit about how you got into all
this
yeah so uh i guess i'll say that that i
actually wasn't your typical kid who
was into space i never had this sort of
grand vision of
being an astronaut i wasn't a nerd about
rockets
and i actually ended up by accident in
a meeting of folks who were
working on sort of space advocacy and
as a result of this meeting i ended up
attending this conference
at the united nations where a number of
young people
were present and um one of the outcomes
of it was that we started
actually a young people sort of uh group
that was called the space generation
advisory council and that
group ended up having observer status at
the united nations
and sort of bringing together the
perspectives of young people from around
the world
to provide input to the un's process on
um
on thinking about the role of space and
how it can help humanity
so this group of friends that you made
during this conference
a lot of you stay as very close friends
and in fact i mean you
this is like what it's like 20 years
later i mean you guys a big chunk of you
guys like still live together right
basically you know we lived together in
this hotel
for it was only two weeks but of course
when you're 18 or 20 or whatever
it was this extremely formative
experience and it just so happened that
you know a year or two later
enough of us ended up actually living in
dc for a while
that we ended up getting a house
together and so we would kind of
host folks when they came to town so we
had people staying with us
and then being inspired from some of the
ideas about what the possibilities for
society
can be and thinking about how could we
kind of embody some of those changes
and sort of test them out in in um in
small ways even just in our home
and so you know over time we've did that
we have lived together in
you know in different cities and and i
really are you know like family at this
point
[Music]
in san francisco there's a number of
houses that you've been not just where
you live but you've been influential in
starting the places like the rainbow
mansion and the embassy they're known as
these kind of communal houses these
intentional communities where
everybody's sharing in the governance of
the house and how it operates and
it's living this life for the past 20 or
so
years that has in some ways shaped your
thinking
about seeing the moon maybe as a place
where we could
have a bit of a reset and and rethink
the way
we might build this next community off
of our
our planet is that fair i think i'll say
yes and no
in my opinion what we want to do is
learn from
what we've done on this planet and think
about how we can incorporate that
knowledge in order to do things
uh you know bigger and better um
as we move forward both of course here
uh as well as on the moon
i uh i also think that the moon because
of the outer space treaty as the
predominant
governing agreement for the outer space
domain because that treaty contains
provisions that require us to make space
accessible to
everyone and not to appropriate
territory in outer space
there is a lot in common that the moon
has and
our governance of the moon will have for
challenges like climate change
here on earth and so in that sense i
think it's it's in particular something
that we really need to think about
um extending our our lessons learned
here but also looking at where we have
failed to learn lessons here
and use it to prototype new approaches
throughout all this history right it's
been like the
who's going to get to the moon first the
u.s or russia and then and then it's
been this very
nation-driven thing and i know you know
you guys wanted to see
something more of bringing a lot of
countries together bringing a lot of
different
parties to stop treating this like some
place to be
conquered and divvied up and more like
how can we kind of do this together can
we come with some open standards
i remember some of the discussions it's
just interesting that like it would come
down to even like what type of
plug are we going to have on the lunar
base is it going to be like you know
some u.s standard or european standard i
mean tell me about
you know what you would like to see
what's your vision
your ideal vision for as we start to go
to the moon and build settlements what
that should look like
yeah so i think the example you gave of
standards is a really interesting one
because if you look even for example to
the international space station which i
think is one of
you know the most successful examples of
international collaboration
uh and you still have outlets that
are different in the russian section as
in the american section
so you know getting together and
thinking about
what are the things that we want to
share in in
these sort of new environments and what
are what are the things that actually
can be different
uh i think is also a really important
question okay let's
let's just assume that both china in the
u.s are going
to the moon and possibly trying to set
up settlements
how do you expect this to play out and
what do you see
open lunar's role being in this future
it seems quite likely that what we will
see is
in the next say 10 or 15 years at least
two different outposts on the lunar
surface run by two different
governments from terrestrial nation
states
and and so i think that's going to be
really interesting and that's when we're
going to start to really see the test of
what does it mean
to not be able to exclude other actors
from
you know any particular region of the
surface of the moon
and that to me is is where organizations
like openlunar
can help out because we're asking what
are a number of different ways that we
could approach
thinking about for example property
rights and resource management
jeff bezos has talked a lot about
wanting to set up factories in space and
industrializing space elon's talked a
lot about
different ways to set up way stations
either in orbit or maybe something on
the moon to like help
get to mars more easily like you know i
mean we are kind of like at this point
where
where it might be one of these
billionaires that's like harvesting
something on the moon before
a country because these guys especially
elon move really fast
um yeah so you know what what do you see
as the role of the individual or the
corporation
in all this yeah well i mean i think
one approach would be to say we should
slow down so that we can think about
this more carefully
but i also think that there's a risk
there that if
governments slow down to think about it
more carefully that actually the private
sector will just get there first
and we'll get there with even less
guidance and uh the private actors that
are going to the moon or you know
anywhere in space
those activities uh are being approved
by state governments
um but what happens when you're sort of
outside the eyes and ears
of those governments once you're on the
surface of another planet you know i
think
um nobody knows at this point and it's
going to be important that we choose a
minimal set of things that we
want to have consensus on as an
international community so for example
when we talk about resources on on the
surface of any planetary body
i don't think they're all going to be
governed in the same way
some resources are scarce some are not
so in space
if we set up specific regimes that
respond to the specific nature of
different kinds of resources
uh we will get better input from
different stakeholders
uh that will make our our
decision-making processes more effective
and certain if people want to get like a
better sense of
dig in deeper to kind of you know what
open lunar's about and what you've been
thinking about i know you just gave a
ted talk recently and you guys have
you've got a website are those kind of
like the best places for people to go
and what's on tap for you guys next year
you know as you pursue this
so uh pretty much everything is on our
website
and for our work in the next year or two
i think
in my opinion what we want to do is have
more consultation
in the space community from private
actors from civil society
and we've been just starting to convene
conversations about near-term policy
issues
uh for lunar activity that can inform
what's going to be happening in the moon
and
sort of five to ten year time frame the
last question i guess
it's inevitable in many ways uh maybe
more realistic than it would have been
10 years ago or so are you gonna take a
trip you're gonna i would you would you
be like an active member of a lunar
settlement
oh yeah of course i would
i mean the way i see that playing out
right is that i think we're gonna start
to see
like longer and longer stays on the moon
you know
weeks and then months and then years and
that that process of starting to figure
out
what decisions are made by sort of like
console operators back on earth
versus by those who are kind of on the
surface themselves and how that relates
to the resources they have and
and a sense of kind of um fairness and
justice
is going to be really fascinating